bonjour à tout bon jour à tous alors si
je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est pour vous
parler de rébellion forcément mais de
rébellion plus particulièrement dans le
domaine sportif
alors pour mettre un peu les choses en
contexte vais vous proposer un petit
exercice qui est connu pour ceux qui ont
déjà vu l'aient été dit je vais vous
proposer de fermer les yeux de laisser
ouvert au choix et d'essayer de vous
imaginer en train d'attendre sur un banc
sur une place et vous voyez apparaître
devant vous 4 à 5 personnes sur des
skateboards qui passent devant vous qui
vous regardent et qui vont s'entraîner
un peu plus loin et ils rejoignent les
personnes qui font du bmx et du roller
par exemple et alors que vous les
regardez en train de s'entraîner
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez à la
façon dont vous les percevez est ce
qu'ils sont
la façon dont ils soient bien la façon
dont ils sont coiffés la façon dont y
bouge et surtout ce que ça vous inspire
est-ce que puis c'est peut-être de
revenir deux ou trois mots par rapport à
cette situation
comment est ce que vous voulez juger
comment est ce que vous vous sentez et
surtout comment est ce que vous percevez
le sport la discipline sportive et ces
trois mots j'aimerais vous voulez
retirer jusqu'à la fin de cette
conférence
alors j'imagine que peut-être certains
d'entre vous ont des conceptualisations
des stéréotypes plutôt négatif ou neutre
dû à une incompréhension on a envie de
se dire mais c'est un peu marginal c'est
pour des des rebelles les gens au
problème et on comprend pas trop on
essaie de le mettre de côté
et bien c'est ça me tient
particulièrement particulièrement
parlants hackers ces stéréotypes
négatifs parce que ça façonner la
personne que je suis pour le moment et à
travers une discipline un peu
particulière qu'est le parcours et le
free running
je vous propose peut-être de regarder en
vidéo non parce que ça donne ici sur
scène mais dans la rue
voilà merci c'est bien ça m'a permis de
prendre un peu son souffle suite à des
mots que j'ai fait tout à l'heure mais
pas assez mais on voit ça une petite
parenthèse 1 c'est du parcours ou du
free running du parcours et du free
running du parcours se déplacer d'un
point à un point b de la manière la plus
rapide et efficace portières donc
vraiment l'aspect utile et le free
running cep se déplacer d'un point à 1.1
point d f où on s'en fout en fait on
veut juste à être libre faire des
acrobaties et des vrilles alors je vois
le sujet de la discussion d'aujourd'hui
c'est les sports extrêmes et j'aimerais
bien abordé trois points pour essayer de
mettre un peu les choses dans leur
contexte premièrement d'où est ce que ça
vient
pourquoi est-ce que séné des sports un
peu marginaux voilà on ne comprend pas
très bien d'où ça vient j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer deuxième point qu'elles sont
en fin de compte les pratiquants les
jeunes pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont
attirés ces visuels on se sont intéressé
pourquoi les adolescents ou les plus
vieux sont intéressés et troisième point
qu'est ce que ça peut apporter aux
pratiquants donc le contexte
d'apparition les raisons pour lesquelles
les adolescents actuellement sont
intéressés par ce nom discipline et
troisième point qu'est ce que ça apporte
aux pratiquants alors pour le contexte
d'avoir ici on peut citer si on essaye
de revenir un peu en arrière pour voir à
partir de quel moment il ya eu ce petit
déclic qui a fait que les sports à
risque d' aventure sont nés là mais on
peut remonter jusqu'aux 1950 jusqu'en
1960 avec l'apparition de du surf du
snowboard et qu'est ce qui est
caractéristique du de la mise à mal du
système sportif traditionnel c'est le
fait de se dire mais on ne va plus juger
un athlète sur la valeur au niveau du
classement va venir
ce qui est important c'est plutôt le
bien-être c'est le développement au sein
de son environnement et d'un d'une
espèce de communauté à laquelle il
s'identifie qui partagent une
philosophie une philosophie du fun du
coloré du jusqu'au boutisme la
persévérance et ses caractéristiques ce
qui est assez amusant c'est que si on
regarde au niveau de la moitié du 20e
siècle qu'est ce qui s'est passé on voit
apparaître par exemple
alors qu'a priori ça n'a rien à voir la
notion de responsabilité sociétale de
l'entreprise
et qu'est ce que c'est c'est exactement
la même chose qu'on a on va dire et le
faire plus tôt de performance et à cela
vient s'ajouter la sphère
environnementale et sociale
c'est vraiment trois cultures on va dire
qu'il se mélangent et qui sont
incorporés à partir des années 1950 et
après en europe dans les écoles de
management par exemple vers c'est
exactement la même chose au niveau
sportif et même des auteurs qu'ils
disent mais il ya une rupture vraiment
totale au niveau du de la culture de
manière générale on voit un système
culturel qui est pas que c'est plutôt
sur le progrès social et qui passent sur
l'autoréalisation autonome on va dire
est un exemple assez flagrante ça c'est
les propos de bernard moitié free fait
le premier tour du monde en voile et qui
il était en tête pourtant il arrive à la
ligne d'arrivée et il dit en fait ils
s'arrêtent pas mais par la suite il dit
mais je ne sais pas comment expliquer le
sentiment que j'avais de vouloir
continuer vers le pacifique
je savais exactement où j'allais même si
je ne le savais pas comment pourrait-il
comprendre mais pour moi c'est vraiment
caractéristique du du bouleversement
culturel de l'époque de se dire mais
qu'est ce qui est important ce n'est pas
le classement c'est pas la valeur de
l'athlète s'est pas les résultats
sportifs c'est pas la rentabilité
c'est pas la compétitivité c'est le
bien-être et ce à partir de ce moment là
on a vu l'apparition des sports extrêmes
qui par la suite du surf du snowboard
avec les progrès technologiques sont
apparus le skateboard roller et bmx et
et plein d'autres alors ça c'est pour le
contexte d'apparition deuxième point
maintenant pourquoi
en fin de compte les adolescents sont
ces bruits c'est lui séduit par l'expert
extrême ils ont envie d'en faire ça le
ça les attire ça leur parle mais on peut
l'expliquer par plusieurs raisons la
première avec l'apparition des réseaux
sociaux youtube on peut accéder à la vie
privée de quelqu'un on veut essayer de
montrer qui on est il ya un espèce de
beussent division s'individualiser
s'origine alizés on veut essayer de
vivre des choses puis les choses dans
l'instant présent dans tout son corps et
c'est que ce soit unique que ce soit
riche en en émotions ressenties mais en
apprentissage tout ça dans une sphère
communautaire et bien sâr ajouté au fait
que parfois on a un peu une perte de
sens une perte de sens de soi et on a
besoin de prouver des choses et à soi
même surtout mais également aux autres
et massa ça fait en sorte que la plupart
des adolescents où certains en tout cas
visuellement parlant quand ils voient
des sports extrêmes quand ils voient de
ces espèces de rapport aux risques ça
les attire ils ont envie de trouver une
certaine forme de légitime
légitimisation de leur existence
via sa ya des théories de psychanalyse
d'ailleurs super intéressante le
phénomène de l'ordalie si certains
connaissent c'est assez intéressant
d'aller voir qu'on juge en fait
l'innocence de quelqu'un ou la valeur de
quelqu'un par rapport à une situation
impossible à laquelle on va le
confronter et voilà si si ils arrivent à
s'en sortir c'est qu'il est innocent
c'est un peu bizarre
il ya beaucoup de gens qu'il faut par sa
aux sports extrêmes en se disant ben
voila je vais je risque mon corps je
risque ma vie avec un danger et s'ils
survivent ça donne une certaine
légitimité à mon existence à ma personne
c'est amusant souffle troisième point
donc premier premier point mise en
contexte
deuxième point pourquoi est-ce que c'est
tellement populaire on va dire
actuellement et 3e un troisième point
pardon qu'est ce que ça apporte aux
pratiquants qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on en
retire en tant qu' en tant qu'athlète si
on peut dire eh ben je citerai
principalement deux grandes tendances en
plus de tous les autres sports qui sont
là le le fait d'aller au delà de ses
limites le fait de se sentir bien avant
ccco rapport à tous les sports mais
peut-être vraiment plus à la
caractéristique des sports extrêmes on
peut se dire que dans la société
actuelle on nous impose des normes
on nous impose des chemins à suivre on
nous impose des murs à ne pas franchir
nous nous impose toutes sortes de choses
par rapport auquel on doit programmer
son cerveau à se dire mais en fin de
compte qu'est ce qui est important c'est
d'accumuler du savoir de l'expérience
des habitudes pour se construire un
futur
où on essaye d'éviter l'insécurité on
essayer d'inviter d'éviter les imprévus
on essaye de se placer dans une zone de
confort que petit tapir on croit qu'elle
est bonne et bien dans les sports
extrêmes c'est exactement l'inversé on
va dire en fin de compte l'environnement
le contre on le comprend pas on le
prévoit pas pardon et on va se placer
dans des situations où tout le temps
constamment on est dans l'insécurité
on est dans l'inconfort on est dans le
stress mais dans la peur et par rapport
à ça il ya une harmonie qui est vraiment
caractéristique aux disciplines
sportives extrêmes qui est de se dire on
va essayer la gérer cette insécurité
on va essayer de la gérer cette peur on
va essayer de la gérer cette angoisse et
les chemins qu'on m'impose je vais
essayer de le prendre différemment
ça c'est la première caractéristique est
la seconde c'est de se dire on va devoir
s'imposer des obstacles on va devoir
sont créés on va devoir se fixer des
objectifs est le point central ctec
avant de se dire ces objectifs on se les
fixe soi même on n'a pas de professeurs
qui nous dit on va faire tel
entraînement on va suivre tel saut on va
y aller progressivement mais cette façon
là on doit le faire tout seul soit même
et bien l'un dans l'autre
cette théorie de l'obstacle chaque
obstacle infranchissable
chaque objectif est atteignable couplé
avec le fait que peu importe la
situation dont se trouve dans laquelle
on se trouve
peu importe le chemin qu'on emprunte peu
importe la zone d'inconfort dans
laquelle on est si on a confiance en ses
capacités
si on a confiance en soi si on sait de
quoi on est capable on arrivera à tout
faire et ça précisément je pense que
c'est caractéristique aux sports dits
extrêmes se mordent aventure et que ça
de le pratiquer en c'est un outil
pédagogique qui est extrêmement riche
extrêmement puissant et inconsciemment
ou consciemment ça devient un peu comme
un réflexe pavlovien un conditionnement
de se dire mais dans la vie tous les
jours il va y avoir des obstacles il va
y avoir des épreuves
il y va y avoir des imprévus c'est
inévitable et bien face à cette réaction
de peur d'angoissé d'obstacles de cette
sensation de tomber face à quelque chose
d'insurmontable que ce soit dans le
travail dans la vie professionnelle ou
dans la vie personnelle mais on peut se
dire
inconsciemment ou consciemment je le
répète c'est franchissable c'est
possible j'ai confiance en moi je sais
que je peux le faire et surtout je suis
pas obligé de respecter un cas pour le
faire je dois pas c'est trop j'arriverai
pas tant pis on reste devant nathan non
ou alors on doit suivre ce chemin on va
dire mais pas à pas entraînement par
entraînement en prenant confiance qu'on
peut surmonter cet obstacle on peut y
arriver
ou alors on ne peut peut-être pas y
arriver on va le contourner on va
trouver des façons différentes
pour moi via les sports extrêmes c'est
vraiment cet état d'esprit qui s'impose
alors si on a un peu un peu fait le tour
le contexte d'apparition pourquoi est-ce
que ça plaît tellement aux jeunes pour
le moment qu'est ce que ça apporte
et on peut voir que en fin de compte ce
que je
j'essaye de dire c'est que les jeunes
qui sont attirés par selon les
disciplines mais il trouve non pas un
renforcement négatif de se dire mais je
rentre dans une sphère où je fait part
de violence jeu j'essaye de deux mètres
peut-être mon mal-être à travers quelque
chose de négatif qui va justement
renforcée mais on trouve un moyen de le
contrer qui est vraiment riche et
puissant et donc au terme de cette
conférence c'est vrai que vous revenez
peut-être à la situation initiale où
vous regardez ces jeunes et j'aimerais
que vous concentriez sur les deux trois
mots que vous avez retenu peut-être au
début de la conférence
si vous arrivez à changer ne fût ce
qu'un peu votre perception vous avez
sept jeunes en disant mais en fin de
compte quel est le problème
ils se construisent de ils deviennent
d'elles des hommes meilleurs ils
devaient peut-être prennent peut-être
plus conscience de ce qu'ils font alors
j'aurai réussi mon pari d'aujourd'hui si
par contre vous vous dites il est bien
beau le discours mais en fin de compte
c'est comme que des jeunes qui vont
fumer dans des cités
c'est possible mais essayez alors de le
voir avec plus de bienveillance plus
d'empathie en vous disant oui peut-être
que c'est le cas mais si c'est le cas
ils ont trouvé l'outil parfait qui leur
permettra justement de progresser de
prendre confiance en eux d'essayer de se
rendre compte de leurs limites de leur
corps de leur être du plus profond de
leurs pieds jusqu'à là au bout de leurs
doigts
et justement dosée un peu faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent d'être sans limite de
réaliser les challenge de leur vie merci